if you really want to see how The Jig Is
up this was the first video that I I saw
this morning this is so incredible that
you just gotta get get comfortable in
your seat everybody just kind of like
chill out for a moment this is so
absolutely wonderful this is video from
yesterday AOC did a town hall in the
Bronx in her home district and you'll
see basically nobody showed up and the
few people that did were not having it
with her nonsense
congresswoman none of this matters
unless there's a nuclear war which you
voted to send arms and weapons to
Ukraine toasty gathers she's left the
Democratic party
okay you originally voted you ran as an
outsider yet you've been voting to start
this war in Ukraine you're voting this
started nuclear war with Russia and
China why are you playing with the lies
there will be no neighbors if there's a
nuclear bomb you voted to mobilize and
send money to Ukrainian Nazis you're a
coward you're a progressive socialist
where are you against the war
mobilization he's telling the right
truth you have done nothing Tulsi
gabbard has shown guts where you've
shown cowardice I believed in you and
you became the very thing you sought to
fought against that's what you've become
sir you are the establishment and you
are the reason why everybody will end up
in a nuclear war unless you choose to
stand up right now and denounce the
Democratic party will you do that
yes or no
today is a great day I mean that is so
beautiful now first let me address a
couple things uh I don't know maybe 30
people in there right so nobody in her
own district is listening to her anymore
the squad and I've been trying to
explain this from the beginning the
squad was a corporate idea and a big
Tech idea the average person doesn't
want their kids genitals chopped off the
average kid doesn't want their child the
average adult doesn't want their kid
dying in Ukraine and all of the other
equity-based nonsense and all of the
drivel the and the hatred of America and
all that stuff that AOC and Omar and
Talib have put out there so they don't
really have support yes she has won two
elections I I give her credit for that
in a very small District she won these
two elections so it's not like there's
literally nobody but it certainly is not
as big as the machine would have you
believe put her on every cover of
everything and constantly put her on the
Sunday news shows and everything else
the young people that are yelling at her
there are quite right I thought the
progressives weren't the progressives
supposed to be nice and anti-war why
would we be giving
all this money and weapons and again we
haven't declared war to the ukrainians
when we're not exactly sure who they are
and there are some Nazi elements there
and it's all very strange and suddenly
the more that this keeps going on the
more that we're suddenly talking about
nuclear war and World War III I thought
the progressives were supposed to be out
there screaming uh against War but
that's not really what they're about
when they're in power is it uh what's
really beautiful about that is aoc's
response to that guy basically was
you're being rude so I don't have to
respond to you this is the same AOC who
repeatedly has done what Maxine Waters
has done and many other progressives
which is you get up in their face and
you show up at their events and you
don't give them any quarter and all of
those things so AOC you have opened up a
Pandora's Box baby and it's on you now
so good luck the inmates are running the
Asylum and they're going to have you for
lunch